hey welcome back to the monitor as
always I'm Peter Rubin senior editor of
Wired let's get into it with a new album
this week from diplo's dancehall side
project Maj la is a apologies for the
airsoft patois but the second album for
major lazer who is a fictional space-age
Jamaican commando with a arm mounted
laser cannon how great is that may be
related for the universe is out this
week as always this is an excuse for
Diplo to bring together friends from
kind of indie rock world friends from
the dancehall reggae world so on the
damn south side you've got appearances
from All Stars Vybz Kartel war 21 busy
signal just a ton of artists and on the
indie side you've got members of vampire
weekend members of dirty projectors
though my favorite track thus far is
probably a song called jah no partial
which is where Diplo got an acapella of
an old johnny osbourne song called mr.
Marshall he got it when he was visiting
prince jammy and Jamaica no one had this
acapella but prince jammy and he takes
it and he gave it to his buddy Flux
Pavilion to kind of make a dubstep refix
of it which I know you're going to hate
me for saying I like a dubstep version
of something but this is well in the
tradition of doing jungle remixes of
dancehall stuff which is gone from the
90s all the way through today so Major
Lazer free the universe that is out this
week that is a nice little record let's
talk about comics okay in comics we've
got a new ongoing from Marvel starting
up this week Nova Sonova number one now
Nova has been one of Marvel's cosmic
superheroes one of the outer space kind
of sci-fi guys since the mid to late 60s
he's been kind of here in there he's at
a couple of iterations of his own book
now it was teased in last year's AVX The
Avengers vs. x-men crossover series that
we were going to get a new Nova we saw
him for like half a panel Nova is
finally here he is actually the son of a
previous Nova though not a previous Nova
that was known from Marvel cannon at any
rate it's kind of a small town kid who
kind of takes on the mantle of his
father's old superhero ways now what's
nice about this is it's going to tie in
with the guardians of the galaxy which
is Marvel's kind of galactic superhero
team that is going to be the focus of
2014's
tent pole movie written by jeph loeb
with really enjoyable art from ed
mcguinness really like this so far
looking forward to what they've got next
Nova number one out this week let's talk
about animated television okay starting
this Friday on IFC actually airing
directly after Portlandia as a new
animated show called out there now this
is done by a guy named ryan quincy who
for years and years was an animator and
a producer on South Park so he's
well-versed in bringing kind of basic
looking 2d animation into comedy and he
does that really well this is the story
of two teenagers high school guys best
friends we're kind of losers on their
quest to find love and acceptance and
just when their way through the world it
really reminds me of kind of an animated
version of freaks and geeks with a lot
of the humor of home movies which is a
fantastic animated show from the past
decade it does not this does not have
John Benjamin in a voice cast which home
movies did but it does have a fantastic
supporting voice cast Pamela Adlon Linda
Cardellini Fred Armisen John DiMaggio
really good voice actors there's a lot
of potential here first three episodes
are sly slow but funny I've got a big
expectations for this one so that is out
there it starts friday night after
Portlandia on AFC that is it for this
week on the monitor we'll be back next
week with more pop culture freshness but
until then inspirational catchphrase
here